The death of Iron Man in Avengers: Endgame
was as heartbreaking as a superhero death
can be, and actor Robert Downey Jr. was the
mastermind behind one of the most wrenching
aspects of Tony Stark's passing.
As fans know, Tony Stark sacrificed himself
during the final battle against Thanos at
the end of Avengers: Endgame.
After retrieving the Infinity Stones just
as everyone thought the Mad Titan had them
in his possession, Tony looked Thanos square
in his big, dumb, purple face, declared…
"I… am…
Iron Man."
…and snapped his fingers.
Thanos, his army of Chitauri, his Black Order
sycophants, and his fleet of spaceships all
crumbled away to space dust, marking a big
win for Earth's Mightiest Heroes.
It came at a cost, of course, in the form
of Tony Stark's life.
Slipping away due to the damage he suffered
from using the Infinity Stones, all Tony could
manage was a faint "Hey, Pep" when Pepper
Potts came to say goodbye.
Devastating for sure, but not quite the enduring
final words we'd expect from Iron Man.
So, why didn't Iron Man have any official
dying words in Avengers: Endgame?
According to screenwriters Christopher Markus
and Stephen McFeely, it was Downey Jr.'s idea
to not complicate Iron Man's death with any
final lines after "I am Iron Man," in order
to make the moment that much more impactful.
They explained in during their San Diego Comic-Con
2019 panel that a previous draft of the Endgame
script saw Tony chattering away - as was typical
for the cocky hero - but Downey Jr. didn't
think it felt right.
McFeely explained:
"These actors have spent a lot of time with
these characters.
So Chris and I are very happy [to], and did,
write all sorts of lovely dying words for
Tony Stark.
Robert is not happy to say them, right?
Robert wants to - and knew this instinctively
- [that Tony is] a guy who has talked and
talked and talked for many, many movies.
When he doesn't talk, you are crushed.
And he knew that, and we didn't feel we could
turn in a page where he didn't talk."
Ultimately, Downey Jr. told McFeely and Markus
that he wanted to, quote, "do much, much less"
with Iron Man's death, which McFeely admitted
was the absolute right call in the end.
Tony Stark's passing in Avengers: Endgame
went through multiple rewrites, one of which
was drastically different than even the version
where the hero was talkative as he's slouched
over and knocking on death's door.
One draft of the script that actually made
it to shooting saw Thanos spit at Iron Man,
"I am inevitable," and the Armored Avenger
snap his fingers without saying a word.
Endgame directors Joe and Anthony Russo shot
that version of the scene, which was in tact
all the way until the editing phase of production,
before editor Jeff Ford suggested that Tony
say, "I am Iron Man."
Downey Jr. was originally opposed to delivering
any kind of line - even one that calls back
to the iconic confession scene in 2008's Iron
Man when Tony Stark reveals his superhero
identity…
"I am Iron Man."
…and it took some convincing for the actor
to come back for reshoots.
Thankfully, Endgame producer Joel Silver,
who is an old friend of Downey Jr.'s, was
present at the dinner where the Russos pitched
the new idea and was able to get Downey Jr.
on board.
Tony Stark may have been a hero who "lived
and died by quips," as Avengers: Endgame director
Joe Russo once said, but it's hard to imagine
his death going any other way than it did.
The scene wound up striking the perfect balance
between a powerful full-circle moment with
the "I am Iron Man" line, and a minimalistic
approach that offered a crushing contrast
to Tony's chatty nature.
And it's largely thanks to Downey Jr.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.